hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the aim chess rapid Division 1
winners 2023 it is taking on Magnus
cross in Northern Beck uh defeated Levon
arunyan in the semi-finals and Magnus
cross and defeated Fabiana carwana and
now they face each other this is game
one and before I check it out I just
have a quick announcement uh look at uh
look at this no look at the story uh the
app that we've been working on for the
past two years has finally been released
today it is out officially and amongst
the other schools there is also the
agamatra chess school and uh well I'm
gonna talk about it after I show you the
actual game but just so you know that I
will be talking about that and if you
guys are interested stay after the game
at here what I have to say about this so
let's check out the game another become
the satrov has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to D4 we have Knight to
F6 Knight to F3 and pawn to G6 now we
have quanta C4 and the King's Indian
defense is on the board and pawn to D6
we have G3 and although Bishop to G7 is
pretty much an automatic here and
everyone places Magnus goes for Pawn to
C6 and just to give you a comparison
with Bishop to G6 there are like 1500
games in the database with C6 there are
maybe 50. so okay Bishop to G2 he wants
the surprise another back a little bit
Queen to A5 with check playing very
forcing moves but that usually means
that it's not maybe the uh the the
trickiest of lines with Knight the C3
and not Knight the E4 preparing to
capture here and win some material and
of course another big defense Queen to
B3 with Bishop to G7 now putting more
pressure on White Center preparing the
castle and just castles Magnus trade on
C3 with B capture strengthening in the
center also the D4 Pawn is now nicely
defended and here Magnus just castles we
have Pawn the four another big grabs the
full Center and pawn to C5 of course you
wanna get in on this action while The
Rook is still on A1 uh and uh yeah there
is a one game overnight the D7 was
played but Hereafter upon the C5 it is
now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so okay another by
continuous development Bishop to F4 and
now Knight to D7 and only now that the
Knight was developed he doesn't go for
uh developing the Rooks he actually goes
for Bishop to G5 so sort of wasting
another Tempo uh developing the bishop
but it does come with a threat so uh not
really a loss of a Tempo one would say
Rook T8 Magnus defense and only now Rook
after D1 we have Knights the B6 uh and
now Queen to B5 offering a queen trade
and also if Magnus goes for this um
another but we'll be able to undouble
his pawns but this also means that now
it's only move 14 and you are already
playing a queenless endgame against
Magnus so captures captures and now
Knights the A4 very nicely done as it
threatens the captain C3 and also
prevents Pawn to A4 we have Rook a to C1
and now Bishop to E6 we have rooked the
C2 the problem is okay you could play D5
here but then you really weaken this
diagonal and while you can play okay
Bishop D7 you play C4 then comes Knight
the C3 and okay the Knight is defended
The Rook here is hanging the pawn here
is hanging the pawn here is hanging and
the white starts losing material so it's
not not the best uh so instead Rook to
C2 by another back and pawn to A6 now
Magnus challenges this pawn and wants to
open up the a file for his Rook so
Bishop to F1 and the Magnus goes Pawn to
H6 kicks Away the Dark Square Bishop
Bishop to E3 and now a captures on B5 we
have Bishop captures and now just Rook e
to C8 now if some characters uh start
occurring here then the C file will be
open for this Rook the a file will be
open for this rook and Magnus likes his
position uh Rook D to C1 doubling up on
the C file and now Knight back to B6
with Pawn to D5 now challenging the
bishop Bishop to D7 offering a trade of
Bishops and now Rook to B1 defending the
bishop on B5 Rook to C7 now after the
trade happens you want your B7 Pawn to
be nicely defended Knight the D that's
not a Knight Knight the D2 and now
Bishop captures on B5 we have Rook
captures on B5 and Knight to D7 uh we
have rooked back to B3 the C3 Pawn is
given additional protection and also you
want to get this Pawn to A3 and get this
Rook behind the pawn so here Rook to A4
uh just putting more pressure on White's
position and now we have Pawn to C4 we
have Pawn to B6 and now Pawn to A3 now
of course you know that the Rook is
coming to A7 so you want to be able to
play Rook to A2 uh we have Rook C to A7
and now Rook to A2 Knight comes to E5 uh
putting more pressure on a white
position and here another back has to
figure out how to defend the C4 Pawn uh
and while he could just trade here with
something like Rook capture some B6
let's say Knight captures and C four
Knight captures and Rook captures he
prefers to keep the material on the
board he plays Rook to C2 instead but
now there's a problem now Magnus will
not allow the trade of course uh he
wants to grab the B6 Pawn in exchange
for the C4 Pawn uh but Magnus doesn't
allow it he just defends the pawn Rook 7
to A6 the pawn is now nicely defended
uh Bishop to F4 attacks the Knight and
knights the D7 we have rooked A2 now
adding a Defender to the a pawn uh but
now just Pawn to G5 chases away the
Bishop from the defense of the E5 Square
then the Knight will go back and then
the C4 Pawn will hang so Bishop D3 and
now Knight to E5 with Pawn to F4 but now
just captures uh sorry uh Knight
captures on C4 first of course grabbing
the pawn uh Knight captures Rook
captures and now F captures on G5 so
another big wins his Pawn back and
Magnus plays Pawn to H5 you could also
capture but he prefers to keep the pawns
doubled uh and uh yeah just continue
putting pressure on uh young nother back
so King to F2 another back starts
bringing his King into the game and now
Rook captures an E4 there was no way of
Defending that Pawn King to F3 and now
Rook 8 to E4 uh Rook eat A4 going back
with the Rook now again putting pressure
on the A3 pawn bishop to F4 and now uh
well you could play something like C4
it's rapid and was also very very low on
time already here so here just Bishop
back to D4 uh after Bishop to D4 we have
Bishop to C1 now adding more defense to
the A3 pawn and Bishop back to E5 by
Magnus Rook to E2 now if the bishop
moves you will be able to capture an E7
so King to G7 Ponte H4 and King to G6
Magnus slowly but surely bringing his
King into the game uh Rook to D3 and now
Rook to G4 putting pressure on the G3
Pawn so the King has to go back King to
G2 and now Rook to D4 putting pressure
on the D3 Rook Rook captures on D4 we
have C captures on D4 and now Rook to C2
uh Rook day 5 going after the pawn here
and now uh here we have Rook the C7
which is a very interesting move uh
going after the E7 Pawn but Magnus
completely uh punishes that he plays
Rook to C5 and now Magnus says now you
have to trade Rooks as your Bishop is
also hanging and my uh well the Bushman
pawn and game will be just completely
winning for me but there is a way to
make Black's life a bit harder here
would you just resign here or do you
still uh you know try at least try to
persevere feel free to pause the video
and even though your position is lost
what would you play here like imagine if
it was a Blitz game what would you play
here to make a Black's uh you know hopes
of winning uh as difficult as possible
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is a rook the C6 this
is the move that gives black the most
problems because now of course you
cannot capture The Rook is still
defending and you cannot trade if you if
you trade in Pawn characters and white
is just winning now even if you play D5
it doesn't matter okay the bishop is
guarding C7 but there's Bishop F4 gets
rid of the bishop and then the pawn just
wins the game so uh well okay it's not a
forced line of course after Rook to C6
Magnus would not to take the Rook
magnets we just continue improving the
position uh it's still the most
resilient way to go down and I hope
that's what you guys are always looking
for you know uh make your opponent fight
for for uh his meal or her meal so Rook
captures on C5 is what another back
played he sort of uh went uh down more a
bit more quickly the characters on C5
and now King to F3 we have King to F5
and now Pawn to A4 and he was in this
position and move 50 after making this
Pawn to A4 move that node back resigned
the game and another clean victory for
Magnus Carlsen in round one of the aim
just rapid finals in this beautifully
beautifully played End Game the problem
of course is that okay now c4 and look
at this control there's there's no
playing this playlist pay three let's
say you attack the pawn uh so sorry you
attack the pawn just Bishop D6 you
counter that of course the king opponent
game if you trade Bishops he's
completely winning for Magnus so let's
say Bishop B2 then comes C3 Bishop C1
then comes D3 if King E3 then D2 and now
you either give up the bishop or the
queen comes into the game or King E2
upon captures Bishop doesn't really
matter everything absolutely everything
is winning for Magnus uh so yeah very
very nicely done by Magnus we'll see
what happens in the other games and now
for those of you who are still with me I
will uh discuss uh our our uh uh school
for learning chess a little bit now I've
mentioned to you once on the channel I
believe already and some I believe 3 000
of you downloaded our app but it was a
pretty different app a lot has changed
uh from then and a lot of suggestions
that you guys put in were implemented so
hope you guys will enjoy that as well
but basically uh this is uh What uh what
is happening the app is called improve
and the as it says become the chess
player that you want to be uh the story
behind the app is that um well these two
fine gentlemen uh Dean stacklin Clay
Thompson they are the founders of the
app and they've created it uh this the
app serves for more than just learning
chess for now you can learn tennis you
can learn chess uh very soon you will be
able to learn pickleball but it's uh the
idea is that it's kind of a learning
platform for everything you want to do I
mean at some point even maybe sculpting
or knitting or or just you know uh
um a motivational platform like they
wanna they wanna be present and you know
allow people to improve uh themselves on
on every front but for now we are
focusing on chess and that's what where
I come in we got together through a
mutual acquaintance and we've been
working together for like a year and a
half maybe close to two years now and we
know each other very well and I can tell
you these are very nice very nice people
they really want to create the best
possible app the best possible solution
for everyone uh to to be you know able
to become the best that they can be at
anything they choose to be like I said
for now there's tennis and chess uh
pickleball coming soon and uh well who
knows where where the future takes us
but basically when you click on the link
in the description below it will take
you to this this is the agamato's chess
School you will click join the school or
no first it will take you to this
obviously we'll click to get the app
once you get the app you go into the app
you will be able to
uh joined agat mattress chess school and
the idea behind it is that uh basically
we do not create content my point being
is that okay if you wanna if you really
know where you are at your chess Journey
like you're maybe rated 2000 maybe 2200
maybe 300 and you you know you generally
know where you are and where you want to
go and you really want to master let's
say the neither of Sicilian of course
there are many ways to do this you could
let's say you could go to adjustable you
could buy an ishigiri scores for I think
it's like 150 for his video course and
maybe like forty dollars
um uh for the course without the video
and if you if you gobble that up I'm
sure you will be like well one of the
best players of the of the night of in
the world okay aside from the let's say
top top 200 Grand Masters but you will
definitely know your neither Theory
however if you are not up uh you know at
that level maybe you're at a level where
you don't know how to start improving
how to continue improving how to how to
begin again even studying endgames how
to begin studying openings should you
even be studying openings if you haven't
even you know began starting end games
that's where the app comes in as we do
not create content we curate content so
we take all the free content in the
world we take the best from everything
we take the best from every topic we
take the best from opening Theory from
endgame from middle game from you know
solving puzzles from uh you know
learning about pieces there are lessons
about every piece in general so there
are you know even motivation even how to
approach learning so we tackle all that
but through all the content in the world
and through all the creators that we we
thought were good to to start off with
at some point we are hoping that there
will be even more creators that the app
will at some point have some sort of an
AI interface where it will uh maybe you
know scavenge the inter the internet for
all the best content but for now we are
the ones who prepare that I got an
artichend myself you guys know Gordon I
made a couple of videos about him he's
he's my brother-in-law he also played
you know great players like Gary
casparov in a simul I'm sure you guys of
course know who I'm talking about so
that's the idea we curate all of the
content in the world that's free and we
uh serve you with the best possible uh
course of training for you so when you
start up the app the app will ask you
okay here are maybe uh here are some uh
how good are you at the end game how
good are you at the opening how good are
you at the middle game how good are you
at this how good are you at that and you
will rate yourself and then based upon
those ratings the app will serve uh
certain content to you in order to
improve in the form of action items so
for example you uh you you you know
you're struggling finding tactics you
know you okay Europe maybe you're a 1600
player and you wanna uh play online okay
you play out of 1600 maybe 1700 maybe
1800 players and you play you play an
okay opening you're playing okay end
game but in pretty much every game you
you blunder a tactic you you miss a
tactic you fall for a trick so if that's
your weakness the app will recognize
that and you will be served content that
will improve you uh exactly in that area
where you are weak if you're a complete
beginner of course the uh the app will
try to serve you uh everything in in a
way that where it will be uh the most
accommodating uh for you to learn uh so
that's kind of uh what we are hoping to
accomplish here and I I think that no
one um uh up to this point has uh you
know yeah even tried such a thing
because every learning platform you have
content creators that create content
here you have uh all the content in the
world that is free only curated uh you
know uh for for you to have the best
possible experience and sometimes okay I
could just invite you you know I have a
like over 3 000 videos on my Channel
watch my channel you know I I have some
nice stuff here uh but uh okay aside
like I have a great tutorial on the
Evans Gambit and I'm sure you guys know
that but maybe you guys who don't like
my explanation of how to checkmate with
bishop and Knight for some reason maybe
you just don't uh or maybe you just
don't like me I mean even that is
possible so you don't like me explaining
that or maybe I did a poor job
explaining that there are many other
creatives who also explained how to
check me with a bishop at night and
there are many other creators who
tackled pretty much every topic that
exists in chess and that's what we are
trying to do we are trying to bring you
the absolute best of every topic of
every Creator uh you know
specifically tailored for your best
experience so yeah that being said uh
let me just uh check on on some of the
other things that I might I don't want
to talk about everything because there's
quite a lot uh so yeah uh tailored
action plans expert curated content
gamification and the supportive
Community to guide your journey to
becoming your best self we already
discussed that so the topics are broke
broken down into digestible custom
action items so we also talked about
that which you can create yourself the
app can create it for you but you can
also if you have a coach if you have a
father who is also trying to uh you know
teach you or trying to get you to
improve you have a grandpa who is also
really really keen on chess and he wants
to help you improve he also wants to
maybe improve himself you can add them
in the app to your team and they can
also create action items for you they
know you're weak in the end game and
they know you're you're you know Rook
end game is really bad and they can give
you action items to improve your uh Rook
game and you will be able to tackle
these action items you know on the bus
on your way to the bar or the library or
you know just doing any you know you're
taking a bath you can also do the action
items if you have a waterproof phone you
can I mean do do it even in swimming I
mean you can do it really anywhere uh
also uh yeah uh there's the idea they
say say goodbye to endless scrolling we
eliminate click bait and one size fits
all classes with improve you're not left
wondering what's next we guide you
through clear personalized prioritized
steps we already discussed that uh okay
the the platform is of course fun and
engaging I think of it like a video game
The More You Learn and Grow the more you
level up score points win Awards and
compete with others motivation Made Easy
uh everything that we've already
discussed at some point there will be
leaderboards like who is improving the
most uh uh at some point we will also
have uh specifically made tournaments
just for people who are trying to
improve who are part of the journey and
uh you know we want to we want to try
and give you the uh like the best
experience possible and we're really
going to try to do a do a great job at
that as we've taken like really long to
create this app uh it's been like two
years and probably two years since we we
started discussing whether to start
creating it or not I mean adding Chess
at least uh so also uh we know that
nothing beats a team effort to invite
your family friends you also okay we
discussed that you can add your Grandpa
or Grandma your father your brother your
mother everyone can create action items
for you and you will be able to tackle
those action items wherever you are and
whenever you want to uh also uh uh yeah
they said if you're ready to level up
improve is available for free so you can
use the app for free and you can also
use the uh the full version of the app
which is subscription based you get uh
two weeks for free and then after that
it's 3.99 per month uh for for the for
the absolute full experience but also uh
if you guys really want it really wanted
the full experience and you cannot
afford the 399 uh per month you can also
contact us through the app uh just you
know explain your situation say why you
cannot afford it but you like it after
trying it out for two weeks
you really cannot afford the 3.99 per
month uh we will grant you the app for
free I don't know if it will be
available right away but we will try to
make it as soon as possible so you know
we would like you to support us we would
like to support the creators of the
school if if it's not possible then we
would still very much like you to use
the app to help us improve the app uh to
give suggestions on how to make the app
the experience for everyone even better
uh that's uh that's the goal here
uh okay so yeah that's we already
discussed this uh we believe everyone
deserves a chance to improve whether
you're a beginner or expert improve can
be your personal Improvement Navigator
helping you achieve a real result also
that that of course is the final goal I
mean everyone
um maybe not everyone wants to become a
grand master okay you have like a career
you're doing really well in this and
that maybe you're into hiking maybe
you're into riding a bike maybe like
basketball but you really want to you
know hone your chess game okay you're
maybe not expecting to break 2700 uh but
results results will definitely come the
journey will be full of experiences you
know you will meet new people you will
interact with new people uh you will be
part of a great community and I don't
know I think that uh I really like this
project I really like the the team like
I said I've been working with with these
guys for for a very long time now there
are great people and um also I've
discussed with them uh once you guys uh
try out the app let's say for a week
maybe two weeks maybe even a month I'm
going to do a live stream with both Dean
and clay and you guys will be able to
come on board and ask them questions any
question you you like any question you
need answered will be answered by them
if you have any great suggestions even
even if you have you know if you say
like this is bad don't do that we're
going to take everything into
consideration and we're gonna discuss it
publicly so you know I I think it's
going to be very nice uh and yeah join
us today and become a part of the
improve Community where we're conquering
goals and creating the greatest
Improvement platform on Earth the
character leveling up is you get started
now so there we have it that's pretty
much that's pretty much it
um uh it's uh you know been quite a
while Drive we've been creating it for
for a very long time now if you want to
try it if you wanna if you like it you
know do uh mention it to your friends at
the bar in the library you know give
your grandma or Grandpa a link you know
allow people to come on board uh the
first thing in the description below is
an app where you can download it it's
available for both Android and iOS iOS
so you know okay maybe I've uh maybe I
forgot a few things maybe I didn't
mention everything but this is I'm gonna
make some other videos about this as
well uh this is uh now okay at the at
the end of this game making it a bit of
a longer video but you know I I say for
those of you who are who are interested
in this I'm very glad that you stayed
that you listened to me and that you
will decide to to try it out uh you know
and not everyone is going to break 2700
but not everyone needs to for those of
you that are destined to break 2700 I'm
sure you will but you know uh being part
of a a great Community a growing
Community where you will be able to you
know hone your chest skill and
participate in tournaments just you know
have fun on a daily basis I think I
think we're on the right path to
creating something beautiful here uh
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely played by Magnus
and uh sorry for a bit of a longer
explanation but I just um I you know
wanted to properly introduce you to
everyone to the team to you're also
welcome the second link in the
description below will be you know to
the to the entire website where you can
just you know read about the team read
about the broader team as there are more
uh people in the team here uh so you
know hope you like it uh I'm very eager
to think that uh hear what you think uh
do send us um suggestions through the
app but also you can send it personally
to me uh you know whichever you prefer
I'd prefer if you send it directly to
the app because then it will surely be
read I get a lot of emails so you know I
people sometimes tell me I I skip a mail
or two but I really don't do that on
purpose I just get a lot of emails uh so
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed that thank you everyone for
listening to me until the very end you
are a true true master of uh you know uh
uh attention retention and uh yeah I
would like to thank James Eugene Cashman
Brad Roth Michael Marshall bullature
thriller.com John malpas for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the aim just
rapid Division One winners tournament uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out the first link in the
description below uh tell us what you
think see you soon